let's say rioters are rampaging through
an area
someone uh well this has actually
happened right so kyle rittenhouse
comes out and says i'm gonna defend this
this area
i'm gonna stop the riots what people
need to understand about the riots in
kenosha is that
it was several nights of ongoing rioting
you had i think was a 78 year old man
was was i don't know i think he was 78.
his building was on fire
he was trying to stop the people
ransacking his store and when he went up
to stop them someone bashed him over the
back of the head with a rock
then you get someone a group of people
who come out then you get kyle
rittenhouse
and then the media demonizes him they
continue this pressure campaign
what's the next step after we've already
seen this and it's only getting worse
at a certain point there's going to be
more groups like like
like the guys with kyle right now
emerging there's going to be more
people doing this across the country
you're going to get more prosecutors
i i tweeted i think kyle right now i'll
get life i'm exaggerating because i
don't know if life is even an option
based on what happened
but i think they're going to it's going
to be like chauvin it would be life
it'll be like okay we'll charge you two
counts of murder so there would be life
in prison without possibility of early
release
and i've looked at every minute of that
all the video available on written house
i've written about it
extensively can i mention my website i
can't remember i did that
uh if folks want to see what i write
about these cases it's law of self
defense dot com
it's all you need to know law of self
defense dot com and i've looked at
every bit of available video i've done
in-depth analysis based on wisconsin law
of that case just like i would do if i
was retained to consult on the case
that was lawful self-defense every day
of the week and twice on sunday there's
no question about it
the difficulty the reason he's finding
himself charged in this predicament and
this happens a lot in these cases is
that with the best of intentions
he put himself in an environment likely
to turn violent he he appears as if he
went to the fight as opposed to the
fight coming to you
the same issue with the mccloskeys they
went out of their house
to confront the protesters if they'd
stayed in their house and a protester
tried to come into their house
they would have been good to go 100
percent but when
it appears or could be made to appear
that you went to the fight rather than
the fight coming to you it begins not to
look like self-defense
even if technically on what the law
allows it's entirely legitimate use of
force
uh i don't i don't know if you can
answer this but uh i'll ask anyway
and if you can't just feel free say so
but do you think written house is gonna
get life
again it's one of these situations much
like the chauvin trial where you have to
ask yourself
is this case actually being decided on
the legal merits
on the legal merits it looks to me like
self-defense 100 percent
all three events uh he was involved in
but if it's not being judged on the
legal merits then it's just a political
witch trial
essentially uh and then the outcome is
all depending on
well the political dynamics the
propagandizing around it and of course
people are not getting both sides of the
story again
let me ask you a bit about this case i
don't know if you're able to opine uh
more on the written house stuff but you
you know uh
so two people died a third person had
his his i believe his right bicep was
was blown off
uh you just said that it was
self-defense every day of the week and
twice on sunday right
if he used more force against that last
person would that have been justified
against the person shot in the arm yeah
yeah so well you're privileged to use
force
as long as necessary to neutralize the
deadly force threat against you once
that deadly force threat is neutralized
you're not privileged to use force
anymore
so to the extent the person could no
longer constitute a deadly force threat
then rittenhouse would not be privileged
to use force anymore by the way would he
but would he know that right so the
issue is this guy had a gun and it's it
all
is a factor of his reasonable
perceptions
um so it's quite possible by the way in
the written house case
there's cases we call awful but lawful
where both parties could believe they're
justified in what they're doing
so the two guys who are chasing written
house down the street
they may have legitimately believed that
they were chasing someone who just
committed a murder of the first guy in
the parking lot
right they could have believed that that
doesn't make rittenhouse's use of
defensive force unlawful because his
conduct is judged by his reasonable
perceptions
if he believes he just defended himself
against gun guy number one and now he's
being further attacked by guys two and
three well he's privileged to defend
themselves himself
against the reasonably apparent threat
those people present
so i i guess the way i i was looking at
it is you know it was
we had a conversation before the show
this third guy
um i forget his name he's got a gun he
had a he had i probably had a nine
millimeter do you know kind of weapon it
was i'm not sure
a handgun of some kind i'm not sure and
he tried to take he tried to grab the
gun
from written house who then fired once
right right
house then backs off
is am i wrong in saying that in that
moment if it were you
you could have fired at the guy again if
he still had the gun and appeared in a
position to use it then it's he's still
a deadly force threat i mean
the person's attacking you with the gun
and they say they're gun and there were
still gunshots going off apparently
i think i could be wrong it's been a
while since we we covered this but even
after he he shot the guy then he gets up
and he looks around and then just turns
around and calmly starts walking back i
was surprised at his demeanor
it felt like he had written house's
demeanor written house's demeanor
yeah of course it's hard to know what's
going on in his mind but of course he
saw the police right at the end of the
street right so he was running
to safety it appeared that he
neutralized his attacker so now he was
able to proceed to safety i mean he
didn't run and hide
right and presented themselves to the
cops which is
not the conduct of someone who's just
committed murder i guess what i'm saying
is that it feels like
um he he a lot of people have said that
he was in control he was you know very
much like
he he he knew where to like
he de-escalated essentially right i
guess what i'm trying to say is if
somebody was sitting in front of me with
a nine millimeter in their hand
i'm not just going to like calmly back
away as they're standing there
still holding the gun and he did
yeah again it's difficult to know what's
in his mind i mean we make as human
beings we make
we do we tend to engage in a lot of mind
reading from a person's demeanor we
ask ourselves hey if i was in that
situation would i act the same way or if
i were acting that way what would that
tell me about my own internal thought
processes
but it's very dangerous to do that
especially in the context of violent
confrontations most of us are not in
violent confrontations most of us
haven't been in a fight since junior
high school or wherever
it really affects how your the way your
mind
captures and stores and processes
information and makes decisions
under stress especially life-threatening
stress is completely different than the
normal experience so
even written house if you'd asked them
ahead of time if you'd shown them that
video of someone else involved in that
would have said
oh i never would have acted that way but
you don't know until you're actually in
a situation well that's that's
one of the jokes we've seen in the
mikaya bryant case it's my
briar i'm getting a name right right is
that i believe that's correct
okay yeah so uh you're seeing people
saying like why didn't he shoot the
knife out of her hand
as have you seen that people actually
tweeted this
as if in a split second when someone
draws the knife and you have
a tenth of a second to make the decision
you could aim for the hand and lead the
target as the knife is moving forward
to hit just the knife and not the person
behind the knife right
this is what people think he had nine
seconds to decide what he was going to
do that instance he got out of his car
this was already underway nine seconds
between figuring out there's a reason
every law enforcement officer in the
country everyone who takes a
self-defense course for using a gun is
taught to shoot center
mass on the threat because you need
those rounds to hit the actual threat
not hit innocent people
downrange of the actual threat um and
and by the way
it's unfortunately like jurors won't
know that right we might know that we've
taken a self-defense course
but most jurors don't know anything
about self-defense they might think it's
perfectly reasonable to try to shoot a
knife out of someone's hands it's one of
the reasons i tell people
there's no way just like in a physical
fight i don't care what your training is
your martial arts skills how good you
are with a gun or a knife or whatever
there's no way to reduce
the risk of the physical fight to zero
you can get it low
if you're really skilled but it's always
greater than zero there's always a
possibility you could lose that physical
fight
and unfortunately the same is true of
the legal fight
there's no way to reduce the risk of the
legal fight to zero you could do
everything
legally correct but then you're put in
front of a jury and if you're put in
front of a jury there's a 10
chance you're getting convicted because
that's just the noise in the system
because they might think a prosecutor
might convince them
shooting the knife out of someone's hand
is a reasonable thing to attempt right
and it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous i mean
especially because it depends what kind
of gun you have
it's just gonna it's gonna go behind the
knife it's gonna keep going
even if it hits the knife it's not
stopped by a knife held in someone's
hand the bullet is going to continue on
until you know there's no such thing as
a miss with a bullet it continues
it's going until something stops it it
hits something
yeah so so looking at like uh the
written house case
and everything we've seen from the
escalation of the
lack of justice over the past you know
decade or so or at least the attempts at
stripping justice away and the riots
that have resulted from it
i'm worried that rittenhouse is going to
get life they're going to give him
everything possible the jurors will
not stand up for him especially after
the photos of him i think with some
proud boys
they're going to be like deliberations
10 minutes can we go home now and order
pizza lock them up and throw away the
key
right so you might be able to tell
yourself well they're not supposed to
take into consideration that picture of
him with the proud boys i'm sure that
won't be admissible in court as actual
evidence
but of course the jury's not going to be
sequestered any more than this
were sequestered in the shelving case we
don't live in the 1970s where the news
is on at 6 and 10
as long as you don't turn on your tv
then you're not exposed to the news
we're immersed in the news constantly
uh those images of him with the proud
boy will be displayed prominently
every day of the trial the jury is un
unavoidably going to see it
as long as seeing maxine water as an
equivalent coming to town saying hey it
better be guilty
or this violence is going to escalate
and they'll be rioting the whole time
of course you really need a jury that
has no internet access
almost like right i know you need it's
impossible i know well it is
seems like it change of venues you have
to like put them in a place
so in the in the chauvin trial the
defense made motions for change of venue
almost every other day it seemed like
emotions for a continuance delaying the
trial to a later date almost every other
day
every time they did it the judge
rejected it and the judge's rationale
was essentially
listen this occurred in minnesota we
have to have the trial somewhere in
minnesota you can't have the trial
in some other jurisdiction is there
anywhere in minnesota
where the mob's not going to show up
where we're not going to have national
guardsmen we won't need barbed wire or
barriers the answer
he thought was no so even if we change
it to another
venue another jurisdiction within the
state we're still going to have the same
you know vaccine waters is not going to
decline to go because it's in a
different city
in minnesota i i i hear that and i think
the judge's public statement was that
but if i were to make a guess and i know
mind reading we can't do that
i'm i'm imagining him you know if if i
were going to make a guess about what he
actually thought is
if i do this they're going to come and
burn my house down i'll just
just let's lock this guy up and get it
over with right because the only
solution if that's what you believe if
you believe hey we hold
it here it's unfair it's not a fair
trial if we move it's elsewhere in
minnesota
still not a fair trial to me the answer
to that dilemma is not
well we'll just give them an unfair
trial here right to me the answer to
that solution is if we're incapable
as a society of providing a fair trial
let him go you can't try the guy
i mean you just you dismiss the charges
with prejudice and you simply can't
subject
anybody to an unfair judicial process
could you imagine if blackstone's
formulation was still
upheld to this day they would have said
if the judge came out and said it's
impossible to have a fair trial
and then just out of my courtroom and
told all the writers it's your fault
right they would have burned the city
down and of course the judge knows this
which is
spineless basically they sacrificed this
guy and again listen he might be guilty
of criminal misconduct
i don't know but i do know for sure that
this process
did not show that well so because the
process was corrupt back to rittenhouse
do you know when the trial is supposed
to be i believe it's currently scheduled
for november but
the nature of these things is that
things get rescheduled a lot
uh i'm sure of course rittenhouse could
push for a more accelerated trial if he
wants to we all have um
a us constitutional right to a speedy
trial but generally the defendant
doesn't they want to delay as long as
possible to get as far as possible in
terms of time from the event and the
heat and the emotion
uh i mean there's a case in florida
where uh a retired cop shot somebody in
a movie theater
uh killed him uh over who knows what
throwing popcorn at each other or
something along those lines
i think that that's been seven years now
since that happened and that retired cop
still has not
gone to trial and he's 70 something
years old so i think the strategy is
you know if we delay long enough god
will take him before
you know he'll be subject to a
prosecution i'm worried that
with written house we're going to get
another uh
i mean it's great for for the leftists
for the for the cult they're going to
claim
another victory in destroying the rule
of law proving that they
that might makes right they have the
power and that uh there's no justice in
this country anymore but i i'm scared
about what that's going what
what what that will mean to
conservatives and actually anyone in
this country who pays attention
i get it most of these liberals who vote
for the democrats don't watch the news
they don't they don't they don't care
they don't know whatever cnn said it
it's fine i guess whatever
but there's a lot of people like me who
are slightly left leaning
and do follow the news and it's you know
the group of the politically homeless
the defected liberals
you combine those people with moderates
and conservatives and we are watching
the destruction of the justice system
and the fact that the judges the mayors
the prosecutor
all of these people are so pathetic
and spineless that they would rather
sell
out justice for their own skin instead
of standing up for what they believe in
and leading the charge on principle they
don't it's gone it could be like an
evolution of our justice system if we
if we fix it because i think in a modern
age those people are going to get doxxed
and they probably would have their
houses burned down and the judge might
have had his wife get remember that one
judge someone went to his house and or
one house and murdered like
she murdered her husband and son i think
her husband and son so
i wonder if we can start to have
judicial processes where it's
um anonymous where you have anonymous
jurors like porting into an avatar with
um
absolutely encryption and an anonymous
judge but you could somehow verify that
they are real people
american citizens i just don't see how
it could work you'd end up with some
kind of star chamber proceeding that was
like
a hidden justice situation like from
central america or something
and and i think we have a right to to uh
first of all confront the accusers to
know who our judges are to know who the
jurors are to be actively involved
and not have this information withheld
from you and it doesn't solve the
problem you still have the judge is
going to be known the expert witnesses
are going
to be known all those people are still
going to be subject to pressure
and unfortunately you know america is
exceptional in so many ways and one of
those ways is our
criminal due process protections that we
have like a right to confront your
attorney
uh your accuser a right to an attorney
or attorney childhood this is too big
i've had that happen um
but these protections exist for a reason
it's because they help ensure
something as close to justice as human
beings can create
and when you degrade that when you say
well maybe that guy didn't get a fair
trial but come on he had it coming
right i mean chauvin had it coming he
murdered george floyd or whoever you
think
might have it coming when you degrade
that person's criminal
process protections you do it for
everybody right because none of us can
expect
any more criminal due process than that
guy got not you
not your kids not your wife not your
brother not your parents
nobody can expect any more than we give
the worst of us which is why
we've always given the worst of us those
protections
there are pro-bono attorneys who go down
to guantanamo bay
to represent terrorists we put
nazis on trial after world war ii
and now we have a large faction of
people in this country who want to
destroy that
and did you hear what many of these
people were saying in the chauvin trial
they
you you had prominent outlets saying the
nation said
in a re something to the effect of in a
reasonable world there wouldn't have
even been a trial
he should have just taken the plea and
it'd be over you you have prominent
activists on twitter saying why are we
even holding a trial we all watched it
on video
they don't care for the rule of law no
and that's unfortunate because that's
not really a world
that i think any of us would want to
live in thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you